in a long-running battle for democratic
rule the people of sudan have returned
to the streets their legislature of last
resort in a day of demonstrations and
violent protests
dozens of people have been injured in
clashes reported around the capital
khartoum
the country's top soldier general al
burhan has sacked the country's
transitional government
he's also arrested most members of the
cabinet including the country's civilian
prime minister
and declared a state of emergency
in these pictures taken near the city's
airport paramilitary troops lash out at
civilians with whips and sticks
[Music]
the country's mild-mannered prime
minister abdullah hamdok has struggled
to lead a transitional administration
after decades of authoritarian rule
and sudan's military chief has run out
of patience arresting hamdock after he
refused to endorse the coup
general al-bahan took to the airwaves
today saying he needed to protect the
country's safety and security
adding the armed forces remain committed
to civilian rule
but these protesters don't trust him
the civilian government was supposed to
take over the presidency next month part
of an arrangement struck when dictator
omar al-bashir was removed from power
two years ago i am
but the country's civilian foreign
minister who spoke to us from her home
in khartoum said the military leader had
lied do you feel betrayed by
what they have done absolutely
absolutely this is total design we have
met with him last tuesday and he
committed himself that there would be no
cool and he committed himself to fully
uh referring to the uh uh constitutional
look at me so you say he's broken his
word
absolutely he didn't break his word did
he given to us last tuesday
power to the people power to the people
they shout in a country where the
military has long made the rules
but members of the public it seems have
lost their fear and the generals will
struggle to contain this revolt
john sparks sky news